ماذا ستكون نتيجة
لضربة عسكرية أمريكية أو سعودية على
إيران الآن حرب شاملة أنت
تدلي
ببيان خطير للغاية.  لا نريد الحرب ،
لا نريد الدخول في مواجهة عسكرية ،
نعتقد أن المواجهة العسكرية
القائمة على الخداع أمر
مروع ، سيكون لدينا الكثير من الضحايا
لكننا لن نكون مرتبطين بالدفاع عن أراضينا
ضع نفسك في مكان المملكة العربية السعودية  إذا
كان هناك هجوم على الأراضي الإيرانية ذات السيادة
بصواريخ كروز التي تم إطلاقها
من المملكة العربية السعودية ،
فماذا سيكون رد إيران جيدًا ،
فهم يختلقون ذلك ،
لماذا يريدون اختلاق ذلك بأنه
كان من الأراضي الإيرانية ،
حيث أعلن اليمنيون مسؤوليتهم عن ذلك؟
لقد قدموا معلومات حول
أنهم أجابوا على كل
حملة التضليل السعودية حول حقيقة
أنهم شنوا هذا الهجوم ضد
المملكة العربية السعودية دفاعًا عن النفس الآن
يريدون  o إلقاء اللوم على إيران من
أجل تحقيق شيء وهذا هو السبب في أنني
أقول إن هذا التحريض للحرب
لأنه قائم على الأكاذيب إنه مبني على
الخداع.